be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff so as we
continue our discussion on Jonathan
Hickman's fantastic for what we do here
is we actually tie in to the events of
old man Logan now this is really cool
because a lot of people don't know that
the Fantastic Four from Jonathan Hickman
tied it into old man Logan actually
followed up to it and told us what
happened after the story came to an end
now somebody keep in mind is that the
Secret Wars version of old man Logan
actually reckoned this information from
Hickman's Fantastic Four and so this
information Hickman's run isn't really
applicable anymore for those of you guys
who don't know retcon is retroactive
continuity that means that somebody goes
in and changes things removes things and
so because the old man Logan Secret Wars
event had basically provided new
information this information here isn't
really relevant anymore with regards to
the larger Marvel Universe but for the
sake of our discussion and Hickman's run
of the Fantastic Four we can use this
because it's still self-contained and
it'll be very important to understand
the things that happen later on down the
line but for those of the eyes who never
read old man Logan this was a story that
was written as an alternate universe
that basically depicted a world where
the supervillains had taken over
everything what it up happening here is
that because humanity and superheroes
were not necessarily as powerful as the
villains there were always a multitude
of circumstances whereby the villains
could have taken over but the reason why
they didn't was because they could never
work together they had their own agendas
they were infighting they wanted to
destroy their own nemesis or maybe they
just simply wanted to take over the
world but for whatever reason they
thought only about themselves and they
weren't thinking about other things and
so what ended up happening here is that
within the realm within the universe of
old man Logan under the leadership of
the Red Skull the super villains of the
world lost multiple attacks against the
superheroes of the world at the same
time meaning the Fantastic Four the
Avengers the Inhumans the x-men they
were all attacked simultaneously now
these attacks weren't necessarily done
by brute force which is to say the
supervillains didn't just charge
buildings and attack everyone instead
they use stealth they use guile and they
use espionage to achieve their goal
within the realm
old man Logan within the I guess of
context of world reign himself what
we're told is that the spiderman villain
Mysterio had the ability to create
illusions that manipulated the five
senses basically your your sense of
smell touch taste so on and so forth and
so what ends up happening is Mysterio
travels to the x-men mansion and tricks
Wolverine into believing that the
villains of the Marvel Universe are
attacking the mansion and so Wolverine
goes through and kills every last one of
them but once the illusion is revealed
we learn that Wolverine had actually
killed all of the x-men and because of
his healing factor all their attacks to
him did no damage and so with Wolverine
realizing what it is that he's done he
actually goes into a state of isolation
and refuses to pop his claws again now
following Wolverines time away the
superheroes began getting killed off by
the supervillains until there was no one
left to stop the supervillains from
taking over the world
now what were only told what goes on
within the context of the United States
what we know is that the country itself
was divided into sections with the Red
Skull taking over Washington DC and the
surrounding areas in the Northeast and
everybody taking whatever else was left
and so while people like magneto took
over middle America magneto himself was
killed with his section being taken over
by the kingpin but in terms of Wolverine
while he's attended to live a quiet life
he started a family of his own but he
lives under the rule of the Incredible
Hulk
now following the events of these super
villains taking over the world The
Incredible Hulk Roose banner had
actually made it with his cousin
she-hulk because as he explained it she
was the only one that he could Poe
create with and so the result was that
they produce a litany of incestuous kids
that were the events during old man
Logan would have Hawkeye show up at the
front door of Wolverine for the purpose
of having Logan accompany him across the
country in an effort to take Super
Soldier Serum to the various underground
resistance groups in New York in order
to improve their efforts to defeat the
super villains with Wolverine being gone
we actually learned that the family of
the
Hulk killed his family and so once the
entire effort of the resistance movement
is shown to have been a ruse by the Red
Skull for the purpose of eliminating
what was left of the superhero community
when Wolverine gets back home he finds
out that his entire family has been
killed by Bruce banners family and so in
response he pops his claws for the first
time in something like 50 years and
kills the Incredible Hulk as well as
virtually everybody else in his family
save for the Incredible Hulk son Hulk
jr. now we're old man Logan ended with
Wolverine taking Hulk jr. and riding off
into the sunset we didn't know how
things ended we didn't necessarily know
what came next
with Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
it follows up to that what we're told is
that following this Wolverine he
basically initiated a giant resistance
group bringing together various humans
and what was left of the superhero
community that was in hiding and led a
revolution against all the supervillains
of the world killing them all and taking
the planet back and so where humanity
spent the next several decades even the
next hundred years basically going
through and rebuilding itself about five
hundred years after the events of old
man Logan ended Galactus returned and
tried to consume the planet now by this
time hope jr. is old and he actually
looks almost identical to the maestro
from The Incredible Hulk stories which
they'll find down in the description of
this video but what we learn is that the
remaining superheroes are those
superheroes who have began developing
new powers and mutants who have emerged
basically leading attack against
Galactus but a multitude of them are
completely obliterated by the power that
Galactus possesses none while Galactus
is defeated because he's basically
killed ones up happening is hope jr.
alongside various other individuals
begin terraforming Galactus turning him
into an object that can be used to
travel into the past for the purpose of
preserving humanity and the reason why
is because as time progressed one of the
planet had been consumed by Galactus or
not it was going to become uninhabitable
for a variety of reasons and humanity
would simply cease to exist and so what
this does is this actually jumps back to
the present day and we pick up with the
Fantastic Four alongside a relatively
new character named Alice
moy now Alyssa Moy was introduced as
part of Mark Miller's run on the
Fantastic Four prior to Jonathan
Hickman's run and what Alyssa Moy was
established as being was the girlfriend
or I guess the ex-girlfriend of Reed
Richards prior to his marriage to Susan
storm and Alyssa Moy it's actually asked
smart as Reed Richards is and so the
conclusion that Alyssa Moy came to was
that by virtue of terraforming by virtue
of pollution a multitude of other
problems the earth at some point in the
future would become uninhabitable now
this does not mean that Alyssa Moy knew
that old man Logan was going to happen
in fact old man Logan is now an
alternate reality so that future will
not happen but because of the fact that
she believes that the earth is going to
become uninhabitable at some point in
time she alongside a man named Ted
Castle who's also as intelligent as Reed
Richards had developed something called
new world and this was basically an
artificially created planet earth that
would exist so that when the time came
that the normal earth was not habitable
anymore humanity could move from the
normal earth to new earth and lived
there and so when it's up happening is
once Hulk jr. and those various forces
from the future travel into the past in
an effort to save humanity they
encounter resistance from the Fantastic
Four who don't want their planet to be
destroyed before it needs to be and so
what happens here is once a conflict
begins to quell once a Fantastic Four
and Hulk jr. and the various other
forces begin to talk them down and
realize what's going on ultimately the
Fantastic Four hood The Incredible Hulk
and those individuals on new world and
then send them on their way now the
reason why I brought this up and the
reason why this matters is that for
those of you guys who were reading time
runs out by Jonathan Hickman the events
that led into secret Wars there was a
comic whereby Captain America
obtained the time Jim and began jumping
forward in the future and there was one
instance where by Ultron had taken over
the world
that was not the age of Ultron story
what that was was Alex Ultron during the
events when the Incredible Hulk and
those individuals in the future were
trying to preserve their planet there
was one being named Alex Ultron who was
actually the epitome of the Ultron
program in terms of an individual
meaning that from the time that Ultron
was first created by Hank Pym up until
that point in time Alex Ultron
represented the peak of the Ultron
programming and so what ends up
happening is that once they're set on
new world and they're sent off along
their way Alex Ultron begins to evolve
and begins to grow to the point where it
actually goes out on its own and then
creates a planet Ultron in and of itself
and then eventually comes back to earth
and tries to take things over again now
again that was an alternate reality but
I just wanted to bring that up because I
wanted to show you guys how everything
and Jonathan Hickman's writing is all
interconnected but again we'll get back
into a Franklin Richards future self
restoring the powers of his younger self
in the next video because what we're
actually gonna find is there's a lot
going on there's all different kinds of
things behind the scenes and that this
is really all just a story about a son
trying to save his dad with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it and I'll
catch you guys later peace
so as we get back into the pattern of DC
rebirth what I want to do here is have a
discussion on Nightwing and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of all this
you'll walk away with a better
understanding of Dick Grayson as well as
what DC rebirth means for his character
regarding the foreseeable future
so much like the rest of DC's rebirth
line of comics Nightwing
gives us a return to the pre new 52 era
of his character or combining it with
popular elements from the new 52 to
sidetrack here when DC initiated the
line wide reboot of their various
characters teams and universes Dick
Grayson stood as one of the handful of
characters being watched closely by
comic fans the reason for this was that